let's talk about the gun control push
and whether this time things might
actually be different senior political
analyst Brit Hume is with us then I
could even break you know we have had
turning points in the past we had the
Sandy Hook elementary school shooting in
Connecticut
with the pulse nightclub shooting in
Orlando the Las Vegas shooting in the
wake of all of those that were calls for
more gun control or at least you know in
the in the wake of Las Vegas a ban on
those so-called bump stocks yet over a
hundred pieces of gun control
legislation have gone nowhere will will
anything change this time around well it
feels general as if something might
partly it's because of the accumulation
of these incidents and the public's
reaction to them partly I think it's
that these young students who have come
forward no you saw them yesterday on the
sunday shows and they're planning is
you're heard the March next month have
been quite effective it seems to me so
there's a sense a couple of the fact
that the president is now talking about
doing something to strengthen the
background check system and make it work
a little better that we might get at
least something this time around however
I think it's fair to add John that in
this particular case we have you know a
real culprit in the sense of the FBI and
the local authorities in Florida doing
doing such a poor job of responding to
the clear warnings they had that this
young man this very young man it was
identified to them by name was a danger
and you know the FBI dropped the ball
and so the local authority so it's
possible that something could be done to
you know encourage a better response but
it looks like you know that will take
some of the focus off more gun control
the president as you mentioned is 12
people at mar-a-lago over the weekend
that he could come out in favor of
strengthening background checks it's the
the bill being floated by a senators
John Cornyn and Senators Chris Murphy
but really all this would do was just
improve the application of current law
so would that really change anything
well it no it it what a bit might but we
don't know that
but you're right it is all about current
law and it's about the failure of
current law to do the job just as in
this particular case we saw the failure
of authorities to do their job so what
you know what might come out of this
would be a resolve in that area weather
or anything you know first of all you
have this problem John we always have
this when we have these these episodes
where some weapon is used or some
circumstances encountered here and it
turns out that what's being proposed to
address it wouldn't have addressed the
the case in particular mm-hmm now I
suppose you know this was not a banned
weapon and you know the semi-automatic
weapon was not efforts to ban those in
the past John as you've suggested have
gone absolutely nowhere because a lot of
people who were talking about
legislating against the bill team didn't
understand you know how they work or
whatever so we'll see if this is
different but I think you're properly
you're absolutely right to be skeptical
about it you you mentioned this that the
FBI dropping the ball on a tip that they
got back in January that the mayor may
not have prevented this but at least
they would have known about it the
president tweeted about that over the
weekend saying very sad that the FBI
missed all of the many signals set up by
the Florida school shooter this is not
acceptable
and then he goes on to say they're
spending too much time trying to prove
Russian collusion with the Trump
campaign there is no collusion get back
to the basics and make us all proud the
president was widely criticized for that
tweet Brett didn't did he help himself
by sending that out well I'm sure it's
fired up his supporters from what I see
on social media that a lot of them seem
to like that but those are people who
have already you know they're already
with him and wood will be with him and
it does nothing to expand his support
and his comments about the FBI's
performance or on this case are
perfectly valid but the FBI is a great
big institution with thousands of agents
you know dispersed all over the country
and whether a failure in the Miami field
office or whatever office was
responsible had anything whatever to do
with the extent of the Russian
investigation I think is is doubtful so
I think you know the president was
probably not standing on very solid
factual
around there and the criticism of it
seems to me was perhaps justified Brett
I was good to get you thoughts thanks
for joining us tonight
thank you John